welcome back y'all you might remember
this story We featured on the show last
season students at an Atlanta Elementary
School were asked to dress as their
favorite hero this is so cool a young
boy named Luke chose his teacher Mr
Freeman Luke said his teacher is a hero
to every kid because he's kind and
thoughtful so let's look back I'm the
only black male teacher at my school out
of 54 teachers wow so for him to see
himself in me it really was special for
me he's inspiring kind
funny Brave and I thought I'd make him
happy oh my gosh that's so sweet I have
over 20 years of experience teaching and
I was going to leave the field of
Education I was going to go into medical
sales I had already said that year five
I'm leaving um but that wasn't my gift
my wife said to me your gift is
kids here's where it gets really amazing
a grandmother in Virginia watched that
episode and wondered if Mr Freeman could
help her grandson so she tracked him
down and what happened next changed all
of their lives it's an incredible story
in what we call Best in
[Music]
Class please welcome back to the show Mr
Freeman along with Denita the
grandmother who reached
out so what welcome to the show first of
all thank you very much what what struck
you about Mr
Freeman watching that episode and I I
saw first I heard that Mr Freeman was
the only black male teacher in the whole
school however this young boy who
happened to be white saw something in
him that compelled him to become the
hero for him to dress like him for that
day yeah um it just made me know that he
can reach children in a different way
yeah that meant so much to me I had to
reach out to Mr Freeman I had to find
him because I wanted to talk to him
about my own
grandson yeah so what was Trey like
before Mr Freeman so Trey Trey I think
is the best human being I love him so
much but Trey is a very he was quiet
kind of withdrawn Trey didn't do a lot
like with friends or he wasn't
outgoing um and he was in the fourth the
fifth grade the last year of elementary
school and he was about to go to middle
school and I was kind of concerned
because I wanted him to be able to fit
in in Middle School in middle school
yeah so that is why I I reached out
because I just wanted to to I thought I
was getting pointers some tips you know
what how to speak to him how to do
things differently but not with Joe
Freeman Joe Freeman he he went all the
way he he gave me the phone number and
this was on a Tuesday so your show was
on a Monday um because the very same day
that I watched the show I wrote the
email yeah and on that Tuesday he
reached out and he has been calling Trey
every Tuesday for a year so wow the
[Music]
consistency what have you noticed about
Trey like how ever since working the
changes in Trey are amazing Trey um has
a lot of friends now Trey he he used to
so cute
yeah so so that is actually a picture of
Mr Freeman went to Mexico and he had he
had on this cool out probably had a good
time okay and Trey loved Mr Freeman's
outfit in Mexico and next thing I know
Trey got the
outfit oh that's so ni so I'm you given
him confidence so confidence so Trey had
at the end of the school year um
Elementary School entered a rap
battle which I would have never thought
he would thought he too shy yeah he
entered the rap battle and won third
place he had a lot to say he just
keeping it to he couldn't wait to share
his information everything he does he
can't wait to tell Mr Freeman so it is
it is amazing and and this is our first
time this is our first time I've never
met him before never met her never met
her everything has been over the phone
so I'm so super excited I've never met
him before and Trey has never met him I
know so that's what I wanted to say so
here's the deal like Trey has never met
him and they've been talking for like a
year by the way the consistency man
that's the coolest thing that you can
provide a kid so thank you for that
consistency is so amazing amazing but
Trey thinks that he's here to talk about
his schoolwork um he has no idea Mr
Freeman is here so we're going to have
Mr Freeman hide you don't want to miss
the surprise I don't need stay right
here Trey is here today give it up for
Trey look at that smile so Trey how do
you think Mr Freeman has kind of
impacted your life how has he affected
you I'm lucky to have Mr Freeman as my
mentor he he calls he calls me every
Tuesday yeah you look forward to that
yes yeah absolutely so I heard that you
had your first dance this weekend is
that true yes do you like dancing I love
dancing I mean I will just dance just
right here for you like I love dancing
well it depends what song they play
exactly it's got to be a good DJ we have
an amazing DJ here Reuben I'm just
saying he plays amazing music so I agree
it's it does depend on the song but we
we love teachers on this show my mama
was a teacher so I always try and lift
up teachers and just recognize how
Angelic they are so what what do you
want to say to Mr Freeman he changed our
lives and thank you for everything
a there a powerful powerful
word well I have some good news cuz you
can tell them that that yourself he's
actually here come on out Mr
fre what's up big what's up how you
doing I'm
good oh
godall
you yall want to SC or right
Miss oh my gosh what do you want to say
for to train first of all this is a big
thing to like speak on a show like this
man you're doing well first of all I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you for coming
to a new city another state for even
taking a chance to talk to me the first
thing he said to me I thought you were I
thought you were
shorter so on the phone you know he's
we've never had FaceTime anything so he
just sees pictures so I guess yeah so
you look a lot taller right now you do
you look a lot taller so um I'm just
proud of you man I'm proud of you I'm
proud of the things you've been doing
I'm proud of the things you've done how
does this relationship make you feel
this is amazing this is all from you
being affected watch then you actually
acted on it by the way I did act on it
and I got so much more than I ever
expected I I'm just overwhelmed
because not only is he's there for Trey
he um he's become family yeah and we
talk about every we talk yes as well as
them talking so we talk about everything
I know about graduations or going to
college buying a new house eating crabs
I mean we talk about everything so it
it's just it really is a family I think
them on both sides so I think it's so
good too to have people like outside
your family to have those relationships
with as well because you might open up
in a different way so I think this is so
special so cool yes I do too I just want
to I want to thank Miss Denita you know
Miss Denita I just want you to know that
I appreciate you and I'm forever
grateful to be a part of your family and
and the loving on him allowed me to love
on him too and I thank you for that
well well before before we go we wanted
to ask about Luke Mr Freeman student who
was here before also known as Sir Luke
um how's Luke doing sir Luke's doing
amazing sir Luke that's my guy he comes
so Luke um he that's him me giving him
the book for the first time his first
time seeing it I mentioned it on the
show that he was going to be a character
in the book sir Luke's in the book he
has on the same suit that he had on in
the uh that we were on the show with um
he's signing autographs anytime he's in
my classroom he's signing autographs he
is uh he's high fiveing Kids in the Hall
he's in fourth grade now so Luke's doing
great um he's another example of
confidence how um believing in a child
can really change the trajectory yes
absolutely well I love this whole story
but I'm hardly the only one our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 the
go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate the powerful
connection between Denita Mr Freeman and
Trey so they're giving Trey
$5,000 thank
you thank you wow thank you oh my God
have some fun do something fun with that
wow well thank y'all for coming on this
show how's that feel College oh my
God I love you so much CU that's what
your braing
if you ever need any extra help on that
you let me know I will always help with
education oh my gosh we need a short
break everybody we'll be right back with
what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going home m